[Music]
what does redemption look like anymore
because I feel like we're wired for
small communities where you get out of
step and everybody calls everybody back
and or there used to be some kind of
guiding narrative like we all kind of
believe the sameish things
regionally yeah yeah and that's all gone
it's gone oh yeah yeah gone so the only
thing you can do culturally is we just
burn everybody to the ground you have to
you have you have a pile of Ashes
everywhere but for everybody for
everybody yeah I think for me is that I
when I was at my unhealthiest mortgaged
all of my worth into the hands of these
people outsourced it yeah yeah I go
y'all tell me what my value is that I'm
good or by the ticket sales or my social
media numbers or my videos are y'all
y'all tell me they burn you to the
ground I go
my I love to tell jokes I love to do do
stand up I love but I cannot I cannot
put it back into your hands yeah I it's
got to be me yep Behavior aside my worth
Redemption would be hey would Redemption
for Michael Jordan be winning another
championship or it would be I
don't I would like to still play
basketball but if I win or lose I'm
still okay worth yeah of of infinite
value I want to be the best parent I
want to be the best businessman want to
be the best chef I everybody goes
somewhere to get their worth everybody
does everybody's on this Continuum
somewhere yeah I don't uh I know
somebody that likes to cook wherever
they show up they
bring that's just their Flex bacon and
everybody goes we love you thank you're
like all right and we again in rehab
another we there was a guy Friday nights
we could do whatever we wanted okay and
but you have to you we would have to
give a on the weekend before we left a
calendar of everything we're going to be
doing yeah right this guy
loved to cook and he would we we all
week be talking about dude we're going
over to gyms gym we all live in these
apartments Gym's apartment he had these
spreads that were oh dude what's Jim
doing Friday I can't believe I can't
wait and then they said hey Jim that was
his that was his heroin yes and he would
come over and everybody go oh Jim this
is incredible and we'd all be talking
about before anticipating it and after
that was unbelievable and that was and
they go hey Jim no more
cooking
and that and then so you have to look
yourself in the mirror now and go oh am
I the was I the cooking guy and that all
the way back to the beginning the
addiction
that that he lived by that his whole
life cuz he felt some way about himself
that if I don't show up with the
stakes do the thing and then but do you
go M and he would what if it's done
correctly the rehabilitation process and
be like
dude and make me cry like hey Jim you
want to come yeah you hang with us come
hang with us yeah and we got food or we
you don't have to cook for us we just
want we want you here just cuz you're
freaking gym and that would be the first
time in a lot of people's lives they've
ever heard that that's right they go
wait you're like yeah dude I don't have
anything you're good you're cool with us
we like hanging with we like you just
for you and some people go that's like a
that that's where the it took me 40
years to get that took me yeah I'm 39
same it took me the first when I was
there you go oh we
so y'all know everything about me yeah
you're still here and y'all still want
to hang to me that's the most haunting
question human can ask is if you knew
everything will you still love me yeah
and it was when my wife was like I'm not
going anywhere and I just want you here
I was one of eight kids that kind of
like maybe didn't get the attention or
love that granted and I and I love my
parents and I didn't get maybe what I
needed right and I would go to church
that was the only place we would see we
were all homeschooled we go to church
there was these girls that were that
loved me and they thought I was so funny
and I couldn't wait to like stuff I
learned during the week is to get there
and tell them and they would be like we
can't wait till John's here like we love
and I I went down that path until I was
35 that's right I don't know if there's
any other
more wherever the love is you go to it
right and that whether it's like I mean
you've seen people in this town that
have are like
influential that I that I that you start
you've seen them verbalize something
maybe like a little bit like
conservative or Republican and then they
got a lot of love there and they just
been it just goes yeah like I don't know
who are you they just been going down
the road where the affirmation comes
from what that what that's it yeah and
why would you doubt why would you we're
all doing that that's right you you do
it in a different way than I do it or
like you go you're a basketball coach
how you ever know known as basketball
and you're like I'm taking the gig at
the recck league cuz in there I'm a God
that's right it in my house it was like
we didn't have any money growing up and
so there was this and I remember my dad
was a policeman and then he quit and
became a minister and I remember at a
young age like oh if that's what the
public thinks of public servants I'm
going to go make money and then they
just kind of chased it and chased it and
I remember it was last year like this is
still pretty fresh that my wife was like
Hey like
the amount of how much I love you
because how much money you make is full
yeah yeah yeah anything else is for your
ego brother and she goes you can go do
what you want but just so we both know
what I want you what I want is you and I
didn't I didn't have a psychology for I
I didn't know what to do she said these
words and it froze me she said John we
have enough and she turned and walked
away and I did not know what that meant
and that was that was a year in and with
a tough therapist downtown yeah and
saying like hey help me unpack this and
you go it goes all the way back to
Johnson I don't need been singing and
dancing I don't need
to you don't need to tour in
2024 or you know I I'd like to and if it
wasn't coming into like but you don't
you you don't have to I have to no you
don't yeah or I I I got to have this car
no you don't I gotta live my kids got to
go to that school other they don't they
don't it was Jim Carrey I think he said
I wish everybody could have everything
for like a day to realize that it's not
cuzz outside of being a Believer a
Christian everybody out here is Hope is
in a better tomorrow right whether
that's a a raise or a new politician
bigger car house relationship you're
hope you're hoping in a better tomorrow
right and whatever that and he was
saying in m in material I wish everybody
could get it so they could realize
oh don't spend your whole life trying to
get it because that's not it there
there's nothing up here in counseling
they call the tyranny of accomplishing
all your dreams because you go with you
right yeah you got yeah or
imagine being like a comedian and all
you want to ever do is is be on The
Tonight Show you're you're 20 you know
you're working at the clubs you're
trying to get you send in the tape they
say no you're you know you go to all you
move to LA you go to all the meet and
greets you meet the guy you come friends
with the guy you send him a tape he said
no you keep going keep working and then
you're I mean it's hypothetical story
but you're
60 and they go you got it and you go to
a Burbank in an Uber at 3:30 in the
afternoon in front of a crowd that is
and you do your four and a half minutes
smaller than you think you do your four
and a half
minutes you walk off stage and you walk
back out of that Uber and you go oh yeah
oh shoot yeah first time I was ever on
TV early on in my comedy career at the I
was on Comedy Center or something U I
forget the name of the show uh live at
Gotham in New York City they called me
yeah they called me they go dude you got
it you got it I go oh awesome and and I
and I remember calling my parents I
wrote this about the story in my book
but I call my parents and I go hey I'm
on I'm on TV right which is the which is
the biggest and you what did I think
okay I think I
thought um they were going to get a I
thought really they get an inflatable
projector in the backyard invite all the
neighbors and and and I never forget
this and I've since discussed this with
my parents a bunch my mom called me and
said oh we don't have that channel yeah
and that was that and
dude you're like Oh I
thought I thought this
is yeah or we're g to fly there or we're
gonna we're going to Charter a plane and
or what to whatever are like oh cuz it
was about when when they didn't pick you
up for your tennis match and you were 10
I tell business all the time if if he
hadn't told you he's proud of you by now
I like Call's not coming it's not coming
it's not coming and so and he probably
is I know he is yeah yeah yeah I
actually know he is he didn't have he
didn't have to say that that's fine he
have to say that that's fine so the win
is not the Redemption or whatever is not
you finally getting him to whoever he is
or finally getting them to apologize or
finally getting the the Revenge money or
whatever the thing is or the car or the
house or word maybe the maybe the
revenge is not that or not the
Redemption sorry not revenge is not that
it is oh if I don't get that cool I'll
be all right yeah I would like to and
I'd like to he still should get up with
a purpose in life to go do something or
to help people or but if I don't but
it's almost what you just said earlier
maybe the call in
life
um is to be the caliber person who shows
up up so that regardless of whether you
can cook whether you're the funny guy
whether you're the like the smart guy
with all the answers yeah people think
I'm gonna call that guy come on over and
just come hang you come to hang with us
and if you're yeah you're just cuz
you're you I will
say I I I've come to all these
realizations or or I don't even know
what you call whatever wherever I'm at
now my hand was forced so I don't want
to sit here be dishonest with everybody
go you should oh yeah CU I didn't you
should be honest with I I didn't now I
had a chance to respond afterwards I oh
it's so much better to live this life of
honesty or or um Goa I didn't so I can't
sit here like well here's what like but
I think I think you can look and say and
and this is my hope for everybody who
talks about like you know America's on
Decline and this and that
is my wife and I sat at table and looked
at each other like this as adults and
said we're going to keep doing this cuz
if we are everything has to be different
from this minute forward yeah and we got
to keep doing this didn't have to go to
Ash first and that's my my dream for
folks is if you
can at least think I'm gonna get on the
path to Redemption before it goes to Ash
I think that's possible it uh definitely
possible definitely possible well well I
when I when everything happened to me I
go
um oh this is Rock Bottom this is rock
bottom and I never forget this the
therap go the therapist goes no it's not
no it's not you decided this was enough
like he's like you I still have a house
uh a career uh a family that loves me uh
money uh my health uh this is not Rock
Bottom there are me trust me there are
there are there are so deeper there's so
many more bottoms below this including
death right that you decided
hey this is the about you you decide the
bottom right and then you go I I I got
to get some help or I got yeah the
bottom is until you're until you're not
on this planet anymore you have not
reached the bottom I I won't I won't
believe this because you've talked about
this other interviews but um and I'll
just leave with this
the grow like just running crisis stuff
for years sitting with Police Department
stuff the only way through that is
running what running Christ like helping
with death
notifications the only path through yeah
is a midnight black sense of humor like
dark and I can just imagine a couple
guys standing around their buddy and be
like looking over their casket be like
that's Rock botom oh yeah D I mean but
that a sense of humor is
there of the the uh if there's a a thing
in your family you got to go you we can
all joke about everything but the one
thing you can't joke about that's that's
the gold that's the thing that needs to
be yes healed when I was in I was in
treatment and I after I've been there
for like a month or so and you come in
depressed at the bottom everybody's you
know nobody wants to eat nobody want
just want to sleep all day just want to
and then you know you start to kind of
make some progress and your family's
like we love you and you're like you
know if I can complete this I can like
[__] finally yeah the horse like [__]
yeah you said then you can you're like
well maybe I don't know I probably can't
ever do comedy again but I could at
least go to the golf course and go to
Chick-fil-A and you start to be like oh
maybe and then your agent calls and
you're like well you know once you're
you can you go oh you kind of see the
path forward and I was starting to like
feel a little bit better start to kind
of make you know joke around and start
to you know and my buddy put his arm
around me one day and he goes listen I
know you're doing great and
congratulations on the progress and I
really think this is amazing I just want
to let you know just don't take suicide
off the table just I go oh my God oh
which is like dude I
dude that's a great horrible it's
horrific great it d i that's the hardest
I've ever laugh in my whole life that's
the hardest if you say what's my
favorite joke of all time and we were I
remember exactly where I was and he put
his arm around me and it's the such the
misdirection of that joke he go I just
want to let you know you're doing great
I just want to let you know don't take
suicide off the table just yet which is
like gosh dude it's so it's it was so
therapeutic yeah and and a lot of times
a lot of times who is policing the jokes
is someone that was not in that
conversation correct almost always he
said it to his the guy that told it to
me I don't want to give his a name away
his name CU it's confidentiality but
that guy loved me of I knew he did we
were roommates and we cried ourselves to
sleep over our current situations
nightly yes nightly and we and that's
all we had he had he had earned the
right yes and you go well you can't say
or like who according to who you get to
decide that you get to decide and if I'm
at my live show and I'm saying these
things to my crowd they are loving it
the transaction is here yes you weren't
there right you don't get a 30 second
clip spun out yeah or or you could you
like oh you don't understand or like
sometimes you see a that's never funny
it's that for you it wasn't for you and
that's Republican Democrat black white
rich poor you're like if that that you
weren't the audience for this yes that's
fine yes you're like oh but but there's
a whole crowd dying laughing right so
this is our moment you can be offended
like I don't I don't enjoy this comedian
you can do that that's allowed because
I'm allowed to do that but you can't say
this guy can't tell jokes right yeah but
clear a lot of people we having a family
conv dude it's awesome hey thanks for
coming by man dude absolutely come by
anytime you're uh super busy uh yeah
telling jokes yeah going to get my egos
met needs met no you give people like me
uh space to breathe and that's that's a
gift I hope I hope I hope
the this is not a it's not a comedy
podcast or whatever but I go I hope that
if I got I would I needed this message
so I was like I'm made not the other
side of it I still got a lot of work to
do but you go man somebody that would
hear this would be like oh
oh just like before you even say the
horrific things you just like first you
think them then you write them down some
me write them down and burn them and
then you got to say him to a therapist
but even saying it to a therapist is
five
steps before you even say it to a friend
this guy doesn't care about you he's a
therapist he getting H he does not care
right if you said the most horrific
things he'd be like huh and he's heard
it all by the way nothing that anyone is
here's watching is dude yeah but my
situation I have you as a what you do
for a living we've heard them all we've
heard them all heard them
all and they she go oh you're still you
can come hang out with us Flinch that's
right yeah yeah you can come hang out
with us in in a contextual way that like
there's people that will welcome you
yeah that's true you're not alone yeah
and that's the message that I I thought
I was dude that's awesome it's beautiful
yeah well thanks for coming by dude much
love brother see Z I'll come by let's go
dude let's do it see you
there